Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is our friend,
the troll man asking a question which does not
understand burden of proof. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, David Atwan, I know this
question is probably going to sound churlish.
Maybe it is. I don't know. Yeah. So you say that.
Speaker 4: Republicans get caught
committing voter fraud, right?
Speaker 3: Possibly because
they're not very smart with that.
Speaker 1: I actually didn't say that.
I said Republicans are the ones who keep
getting caught committing the voter fraud,
even though they're the ones who
say it's the left that's doing it.
Speaker 3: Democrats could be committing voter
fraud but aren't getting caught because they
are smart. It's just a question.
The reason I ask it is because.
I find it unreasonable or illogical or almost
impossible for there not to be at least
one case of a Democrat. Committing voter fraud.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there are isolated. You can find
a case of a Democrat committing voter fraud.
This is what's called a special pleading and
a misplaced burden of proof. And so the example
that I often will give is someone comes to you
and they say, Sir David, there's a there's
an elephant in the room with you right now
as you are doing the show. And I would say, okay,
well, usually when there's elephants are big,
I don't see an elephant. They go, well, is
it possible the elephants invisible? Okay,
maybe the elephants are invisible. Let me put down
some baby powder, because certainly if there's an
elephant in here that's invisible as they walk
around, they or breathe, they will move some
of the baby powder. And they go now because not
only is it invisible, it's weightless, and it's
suspended in the air. So it's not going to move
around the baby powder. And I go, okay, well,
you know what? Let let me do this. Let me throw
a ball. And if there's really an elephant here,
then the ball will bounce. Off they go. No,
because it's also it's a special elephant where
matter can pass through it and you keep
adding at some point, the burden of proof
has to be on you to prove that there's an
elephant in the room. And similarly here,
the Republicans insist that Democrats
are the ones committing voter fraud.
It's almost never happening. But anecdotally,
it's Republicans that keep getting caught.
So then to come back and say, well, is it possible
that it's really Democrats mostly committing it,
but they're smarter and committing it better, so
they're not getting caught? Well, at some point,
the burden has to be on you to prove that. The
fact that Republicans just insist that Democrats
are committing voter fraud absent any
evidence. At some point you have to prove
your hypothesis about what's going on. All right.
Troll man, please. And thank you. We have a great
bonus show for you today. Russia may be bracing
for a default and rapidly approaching one. We will
talk about the impact it may have. Connecticut
has passed a bill to make the state a safe haven
for abortion providers. The opposite of what's
happening in Oklahoma, as we talked about earlier,
and Joe Biden's support among Gen Z and
millennials is collapsing. Why is it collapsing?
We will talk about it and more on today's bonus
show. Please sign up at join Pacman dot com to
get instant access to the bonus show. You'll
also get The Daily Show. 6 hours earlier than
everybody else. When you are a member, sign
up at join time.com. We will see you then.